So for a long time,
oil is played a special role in American
foreign policy and military strategy.
Oil is a uniquely important commodity in
global affairs.
It's an input to everything in our
modern way of life.
It's very important for protecting our
prosperity and at a certain level,
oil is essential for a high quality
military power to fight.
You need access to oil.
And in the Cold War,
the United States was concerned that the
Soviet Union could interrupt American
access to Persian Gulf oil,
which we needed in order to defend
Europe,
defend our own interests against the
Soviet Union.
And so we took it on as a military
mission to protect key sources of oil
supplies around the world,
especially in the Persian Gulf from
outside interference.
So from the Soviet Union,
being able to threaten them now,
of course,
for a long time.
So the union hasn't existed.
That particular scenario hasn't posed a
challenge for the United States,
but the United States has feared oil is
continuing to play a role in American
foreign and military policy because the
United States has feared that political
disruptions in the Middle East internal
instability.
Um,
uh,
the threat of a extremists
fundamentalist Muslim control in the
Middle East,
if that came about,
could pose a threat to American oil
supplies that especially with hurt our
prosperity,
right,
that they could,
they could make us poor.
And so we've used a military force to,
to try to,
um,
reduce instability in parts of the
world,
especially the Persian Gulf where,
uh,
we're afraid that instability would
threaten global oil markets.
That policy has both being largely
unnecessary and largely ineffective.
So,
uh,
it has happened that there was a moment
where it seemed to work very well when
we sent troops in 1992 defend Saudi
Arabia from Saddam Hussein who had just
conquered Kuwait and then we liberated
Kuwait in the Gulf War but did not
continue to attack Iraq.
And,
uh,
the result of this was to maintain
access to Persian Gulf oil to maintain
the independence of a number of Persian
Gulf oil producers.
And that made sense in a bunch of ways.
Um,
but then,
uh,
since that time,
we've actually become a primary threat
to stability in the Middle East rather
than a primary guarantor of stability.
In the Middle East and that when we
invaded Iraq,
we set in motion a lot of,
uh,
events created a much more,
um,
uh,
salient,
a internal stability challenge for many
countries in the,
in the Persian Gulf,
by,
by hardening and militarizing,
a domestic conflict and a of these
countries between Sunnis and Shiites,
between different brands of within Sunni
Islam or within shaded,
we've created internal instability,
um,
that,
uh,
we can't address very well from outside,
right?
The United States lacks the detailed
information to understand and manipulate
the politics of these countries.
Instead,
we get manipulated by local actors than
in a sense makes the instability worse.
So if you think of it this way in the
United States,
we spend a lot of time thinking about
and studying American politics and
elections,
but we don't understand American
politics very well,
even with all of the background cultural
knowledge we have and understanding of
our own politics.
Nobody expected president trump to rise
as a phenomenon and become president.
Um,
uh,
we don't understand our own politics.
How can we expect to understand and
manipulate the politics of faraway
countries in the Persian Gulf where,
um,
we don't know the local person inches?
Well,
we don't know the situation on the
ground.
We don't know what contributes to
people's political activism,
although we can actually be fairly sure
of one thing that contributes,
which is they don't like the feeling
that they're being pushed around by
outside influences like the United
States showing up and telling them what
to do.
And so we can create hostility to the
United States by saying,
oh,
we're showing up to defend the stability
of Middle East oil supplies,
but we can't actually defend Middle East
oil supplies from local instability in
the Middle East.
Very well.
And so we've actually created a lot of
the problems in the oil market.
However,
all of that said,
the global oil market protects us,
so we don't actually have to worry as
much about that kind of instability in
any particular oil supplier.
So what happens in the oil market is
when there's a disruption in one country
of the world that reduces their oil
supplies,
their ability to supply the global
market to supply consumers like us in
the United States,
when there's that kind of a disruption,
other suppliers compensate.
So suppliers that aren't comp,
that aren't disrupted see an opportunity
to make more money for themselves by
increasing their oil output to
compensate for the fact that one of
their competitors has reduced their oil
output.
So for example,
when a,
uh,
Libya exploded into civil war and then
us and European intervention rec to the
state institutions of that country and
made the civil war last,
not just a few months in 2011 but
persist for the last seven years,
such that Libyan oil output is way down
millions of barrels a day down compared
to what it was before 2011 didn't lead
to a huge disruption of the oil market.
Didn't lead to a big price surge for
consumers like the United States.
Because other producers of oil like
Saudi Arabia,
like the United Arab Emirates,
like Mexico,
you know,
all around the world increased their
output to compensate for the fact that
Libya was producing less and so the
natural market reaction without the US
military doing anything enables
consumers to continue consuming in the
face of political military disruptions
of the oil market in one country around
the world.
So we don't need to try to use the
American military to protect the oil
markets because the market compensates
for disruptions.
And in fact,
our track record of using the US
military to protect the oil markets is
lousy.
It often makes the problems worse,
not better.
And so there's a clear policy adjustment
the United States can make to stop using
the military for this purpose and that
would make Americans safer and continue
to give us a reliable oil supply.